sometimes it's just a great 90s action
movie a 90s action movie that's so 90s
it could be my apocalypse air right now
be so good
[Music]
speed the year was 1994 we had ourselves
an action movie that was first when I
saw the trailer for it it saw the
premise was young at the time so don't
judge but I was like so takes place on a
bus I was allowed to watch right at our
movies back then I was still young
doesn't change the fact that I've
watched it when it came out on VHS video
is amazing this is action movie how I
like my action movies this is gonna be
spoilers I just I want to talk about the
movie that does include elements of the
end so you've been warned if you haven't
seen speed by now I am shocked but I
know you're out there people that
haven't seen speeds so you should watch
speed there's a bomb and a bus when the
bus goes above 50 the bombs armed and
that happens very early on and after
that when it drops below 50 it blows up
what do you do so Jack played by Keanu
Reeves he gets on the bus and now now
here we go simple and premise amazing an
execution what I like is the fact that
this movie it doesn't dick around it
doesn't waste your time it just gets you
there not only when you're on the bus
you feel like you are going at freeway
speed you feel like you're going at 60
miles an hour but what my young brain
couldn't conceive of at the time was the
fact that the bus it's not that they're
just in a bus they're not just on a set
that's the dimensions of the inside of a
bus the bus itself is a character this
bus is running into obstacles it's in
Los Angeles I mean it's not like the
place isn't known for its traffic
congestion so obstacle after obstacle
getting thrown in their way they have to
find a way around that it's very
exciting I was amazed at how much the
bus itself is a character but also the
characters themselves Keanu Reeves Jack
back then the 80s and 90s your action
hero he was either named Jack or John or
basically if he was named after an
alcohol you knew this movie's gonna be
the [ __ ] boss and it was true for me
this is what solidified Keanu Reeves as
an action star I know he was already in
Point Blank Point Blank by namco
starring Keanu Reeves no Point Break but
I hadn't personally seen Point Break yet
so for me it was Ted Theodore Logan to
speak blew my mind but once we get past
all the jokes of lo that we used to make
back in the day Keanu Reeves has always
had that likable relatability to him
that's why he
does Nia purchase neo because he was mr.
Anderson he finds out he was the one he
doesn't just exhibit I am the one he's a
relatable everyday guy who
springboarding off of the concept laid
out by John McClane which really shows
how important die hard and John McClane
they both are whether it be him Sandra
Bullock she plays Annie this also put
her on the map least for me their 90s
action premise romance that's building
but the side characters to banter
whether it be forties or Johnny Cage
they're really one of the most important
things about speed is it comes from a
time when they're making an action movie
ok you know what an important element of
an action movie is the villain and
Dennis Hopper as Howard Payne the
villain he's amazing amongst some of if
not a lot of my favorite action movies
of the 80s and 90s a constant seems to
be the villain a villain who's not just
a villain at the capacity of giving the
hero something to do but a charismatic
villain who stands out played by an
actor who knows how to bring that
character to life in a way where the
character might be fun but not a
complete clown can go toe-to-toe with
the hero and steal the scenes he's in
the late great Dennis Hopper in speed is
one of those villains most of his
interaction with Jack is on the phone
Keanu Reeves and Dennis Hopper do have
face to face in the beginning in the end
of the movie but for the most part phone
calls but you still that chemistry is
there Dennis Hopper just brings it's
whimsical but unpredictable he brings an
unpredictable energy to this villain as
much as he wants to sail it's all about
the money it's clearly not as seen by
the end of the movie we'll get there in
a bit and not only does this movie not
waste your time when you're on the bus
but it doesn't waste your time in the
setup either the setup of this movie is
Dennis hoppers character he's taken a
bunch of hostages in an elevator in Jack
and Harry played by Keanu Reeves and
Jeff Daniels they foiled that plan but
hey Howard Payne has a back-up plan and
that's the bus and then we get on the
bus and then speed but really the setup
of this movie is such amazing execution
in terms of letting us know what we're
in for letting us know where the
characters stand you look at this whole
intro elevator hostage situation you
learned that Jack's the kind of guy who
will shoot the hostage Harry's the more
level-headed one which means clearly
he's not gonna be the one on the bus you
learned about Jack and Harry's
friendship they have some small talk you
know what do you do and you learn that
Howard Payne is a really smart guy who
always has a back-up plan just learn
everything you need to learn about the
characters and the setup but it's
entertaining the [ __ ] out of you while
it's doing it it's not just dialogue
word vomit exposition that you see a lot
of movies do now show
through action this movie does that it's
the execution of the intro in tandem
with the high-octane nature of being at
freeway speeds for this entire movie
well most of the movie anyway just
facilitates the fact that this movie
doesn't deck around I will say that I'm
most interested while we're on the bus
and then when we get off the bus for the
last final showdown I'm not as
entertained now that it's bad I mean hey
I love me a good plane explosion as much
as the next person because we already
saw a bus explode we need to step it up
we need a bus to explode when it hits a
plane and plane explodes - oh it's so
90s it's great I get why we're here I
get how we've gotten here and again it
does show as much as we always knew I
mean we always knew that Howard Payne
was just he was playing a game with Jack
because that's the kind of maniac he is
but he always said throughout this movie
like now it's just all about the money
jack but it's not like he could have
just talked through his little fox hole
and drilled up to the trashcan and got
the money he could have just been on his
way and that could have been fine but no
he takes a knee as a hostage because the
game's not over yet just show us how
personal it is so I get why we're here
but even after Howard Payne is done he's
out of the scene now we're in a subway
and the tracks gonna curve and they
can't slow it down or so as to speed
it's just like there's more to I'm like
we're still doing this kind of stuff I
always every time I watch speed and it
has been many times I always feel like
the movie could have ended five minutes
earlier but it's just five minutes so
then it ends up roughly with a vengeance
it's like I had to done credits oh I
almost didn't talk about the soundtrack
it's so good it's so good that when you
hear it you're instantly like has a
great attention to detail what I mean by
that is let's look at the events that
lead up to the showdown between Jack and
Howard Payne basically from the moment
they turned into LAX they were destined
to have that showdown or at least from
the moment Jack tried to disarm the bomb
under the bus after they turn into LAX
here's what I mean going backwards from
the showdown that got there because
Howard Payne realized that they had just
one minute of footage looped they only
had one minute of footage looped because
they could only record for one minute
because they didn't have enough time
they didn't have enough time because the
bus was leaking gas the bus was leaking
gas because Jack stabbed the gas tank
Jack stabbed the gas tank because chunks
of broken tire hit his car chunks of
broken tire hit his cart because the bus
ran over tire spikes the bus ride over
tire spikes when it turned into
there's a direct line of succession of
cause and effect from when they turn
into LAX to the showdown with Howard
Payne and Jack I'm not saying it's the
only movie that does I'm not saying a
lot of movies don't I'm saying keep in
mind I see a lot of [ __ ] movies but a
yearly basis so when I see a movie so
easily display it I appreciate you've
heard me say that a lot in reviews right
where I'm like it's like things were
happening for the sake of happening what
I'm trying to say is the movie doesn't
have the brain speed hat it just speaks
of what I mean when I say the movie
doesn't waste our time because it
doesn't waste its time either it has a
concept of one thing leads to the next
thing because it knows that if the
movies wasting its time then it is by
proxy wasting your time you can argue
that in movies everything is a cause
Alvin like one thing always leads to the
next and that's true for the most part
but not in a way that's done this well
with this many links like most movies if
someone ran over tire spikes it would
lead to one thing that would be a
problem not one thing that leads to
another at least to another I just
thought that was really well done in
here guys in the end speed it's just
it's a great 90s action movie that's the
kind of 90s action movie I feel like we
just we don't make anymore there may be
movies made now that throwback to 90s
action movies but they still do feel
like movies today that are doing it for
the sake of throwing back to speed came
out it was just the way when movies
could have a simple yet kind of cheesy
premise on papers like a bus that goes
over what but they can lean into it in a
way that just made it fun they had good
character moments she had good moments
of friendship you had a hero you could
relate to
charismatic villain played by a great
actor he's just having a lot of fun with
it there's a lot that works with speed
not a lot that doesn't it's the kind of
movie I can just watch at any time any
day I don't have you it's not like you
mentally have to be in the mood for
speed you're always in the mood for
speed and I think that comes from the
fact that it is an easily accessible
simple premise simple makes it sound bad
it sounds like a negative but I mean
that as a positive it's easily
accessible and it doesn't waste your
time and speed absolutely is awesome
tacular
alright so speed have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's a 90s
action movie you'd like me to review
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]